هنا في محافظه عثمانيه تركيه تحولت عربات
القطار الى مساكن تؤوي مشردين جراء
الزلزال حيث قررت سلطات الولايه تخصيص
عربات القطار المتوقفه في المحطه لصالح
نحو الف شخص شردهم الزلزال حين الانتهاء
من مشاريع الاسكان
من اسطنبول لا ينضم الينا مسؤوله علاقات
الشرق الاوسط في هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
اهلا بك سيد بدايه نسالك عن جهودكم وما
ابرز ما تقومون به في الفتره الحاليه
اهلا وسهلا بكم طبعا
يعني الابرز الامور التي نقوم بها الان في
ميدان هي طبعا تقريبا في كل المجالات التي
تحتاجها المشردين او المتضررين من الزلزات
ونتحدث باكثر عن ان يتعلق بالايوان كما
نعرف ان اكثر من مليون تقريبا مليونين شخص
مشرد على الشوارع ولجاوا الى اماكن مختلفه
وعلى الخيم مثل هذه السكنات الطلابيه ومثل
هذه السكنات لكن طبعا هذه كثير من الناس
على الشوارع دون خيم فنحن
اكثر على موضوع الايواء بما
يتعلقوا نقوم ببناء الحي من بيوت الجاهزه
التي هي الكونتينرات مكون من 21 متر مربع
ممكن كل المكوناته في داخل هذا نركز فيها
اكثر لان في احتياجات في هذا المجال لكن
مع ذلك يعني نستطيع ان نقول ما يتعلق
بالاغذيه وما يتعلق بالصحه وما يتعلق
بالدعم النفسي
للمتضررين لان الاثر كثير على الناس على
الاطفال على الكبار
فنحتاج ان ان نعمل في اغاثه الانسانيه من
كل اطراف حتى يكون شامل كامل لكن طبعا ليس
كمؤسسه نحن فقط تكفي ان نقوم بهذا لابد ان
تقوم كل المؤسسات المحليه والدوليه ان
تساعد في هذا الامر وراينا التضام كبير
موجود في داخل تركيا لكن لو ننظر الى عدد
التي تضررت حقيقه كبيره لان اليوم بالفعل
يعني لما تحدثنا عن ان مدينتي نورداغ
والاصلاحيه سيتم هدم جميع المباني فيها
كذلك 50% من المباني فيها تايت تضررت في
غازي عنتاب كذلك العدد كبيرا نتحدث عن 80
الف مبنى يعني الموضوع كبير جدا هل يمكن
اعاده الاعمار في سنه مثل ما تتواعد او
تقول السلطات التركيه
طبعا السلطات التركيه قامت بالتصريح سنه
لكن هذه بعد ان تمت الاحصائيات عن عدد
المباني التي
تهدمت وتهدمت جزئيا او بما نسميه جزئيه
متوسط او صغير فلذلك نتوقع ان تكون اكثر
من سنه بقليل ممكن تكون سنه ونصف لكن هذا
العدد نتحدث اليوم قامت بالحكومه بالتصريخ
يعني نعرف ان السبعه الاف من المبنى تحدمت
كامله واكثر من خمسين الف هي تهدمت جزئي
كبير لابد ان انني يهدم بشكل كامل ونتحدث
عن فقط الذي تهدمت جزئيه
224 الف سكن انا شقه للناس وهذا تقريبا
مليون ونصف ومع ذلك في كذلك فوق 100 الف
سكن متضرره خفيفه لكن هل الناس حقيقه
[موسيقى]
ماذا عن نقل المساعدات الطبيه
والغذائيه
والخيم كذلك للمتضررين في اي ظروف تسير مع
العلم ان هناك قرى الطرق اليها
مكسره
وتتم نقل المساعدات عن طريق الطائرات
في طرق مختلفه طبعا في
الطائرات التي توصل مساعدات وطرق التي
تضررت تقوم البديل من الطرق لكي توصل
المساعدات على الاقل بشاحنات الكبيره نحن
كمؤسسه يعني قمنا بفكره جديده التي في
الميدان في بعض المطبخ
موجود في تلك المنطقه نتفق معهم يطبخون
لنا مثلا مع كثير من الوجبات ونوصلهم
بسيارات او بالدرجات الناريه ونوصل الى
القرى والى المناطق التي صعب ان تصل اليها
الشاحنات الكبيره
بهذه الطريقه تصل المساعدات الاغذيه الى
الناس الذي بشده الحاجه
لكن يعني طبعا الحاجه الكبيره الان يعني
بدا الكثير من الاحياء
سيبدا الانشاء في بما يطلب البيوت الجاهزه
وفي النقاط معينه
التوزيع المساعدات والناس الان طبعا قليلا
يعرفون الاماكن ويجمعون في تلك المناطق
لكي ياخذون المساعدات لكن بها هذه البارده
القارسه
وكل ما تراكم من الالام ما نسميه يعني
كثير بكلام حقيقه هي كثيره يعني
مسؤول علاقات الشرق الاوسط في هيئه
الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه حدثنا من
اسطنبول